joining us now from the trump
organization eric trump is with us eric
wow a lot coming out joe biden well good
to have you thank you for being with us
you've been watching the events of today
i'm just dying to get your response
listen i mean what can you say what can
you say about biden and you know what no
one covers in the media other than you
sean
it's absolute travesty you know when he
says that the black community
is not diverse it's one dimensional when
he comes out with this
nonsense i mean can you imagine if
donald trump said that and you know what
the media doesn't even want cover it i
mean that's how bias that's how in their
corner
you know they are it's disgusting this
guy doesn't have the mental capacity to
be commander in chief of this country
jill biden is spending
more time on tv than than her husband is
the guy won't come out of his
basement he won't answer real questions
he won't debate you know sean
you're gonna have you're gonna have 16
states
16 states that started voting you're
going to have 8 million votes cast
before the first debate and it's
disgusting and it shouldn't happen and
it's uh it's a travesty and you know
what this guy is afraid of my father and
i really believe that these debates are
going to be an absolute bloodbath
well i will tell you this i really would
like
to have that debate i mean i i'd like to
resolve the issues from 2016 about the
deep state with your dad
and i also think it's fair that joe says
he's
dying to debate donald trump let's have
it add the extra debate joe
donald trump invited you to have an
extra debate before one vote is cast
the american people need to see this
do you think it's any coincidence sean
that that you know
they're all all the debates are at the
end of september and into october
you know if you look at north carolina
i'll just give you a great example north
carolina starts voting september 4th
if you look at florida florida starts
voting september 14th right
the debate doesn't happen until
september 29th the first debate and
that's not that's
that's not the last debate you're you're
literally gonna have eight million votes
that are cast before the first debate
and they rigged this on purpose that's
why he won't slide the debates up sean
he doesn't want to debate my father
there's no question about it that's why
he wants the debates as
you know as late as possible because it
benefits him because he does not want to
be on that debate stage and
when you see the comments that he made
today about the black community when you
see the comments the guy makes every
single day
you know last week he called arizona a
city you know a couple weeks ago he said
he was running for united states senate
sean
the guy does not want to debate my
father and it's a travesty that this
debate commission is probably very very
crooked
is allowing them to start the debates
this far into voting
this is corruption at the highest level
this is not fair to the american voter
he swears he wants to debate he needs to
debate
the country needs to see a debate before
a single vote is cast totally agree last
word
well listen i i think um i think we're
looking really good the polls are
looking great you see it every single
day the enthusiasm is
is tremendous and i can tell you as
vocal as as
a lot of our supporters are what's under
the surface sean is tremendous i can
just i see it
i see more enthusiasm going into 2020
than i did in 2016 and
we're going to win my father is going to
win this election oh he's got the whole
media mob
and the establishment against him and
hopefully
he shocks the world in 89 days eric
trump thank you